the internal piece that most people
think of as machine learning that's much
easier than what most people think
that involves putting data into a bunch
of algorithms and seeing what comes out
on the other side and there you should
just go ahead and Dabble Tinker play
give yourself permission even if you
don't understand what's going on inside
there to just try it and the testing bit
is the crucial bit for responsible
machine learning and AI
please make sure that your solution
actually works on relevant new data and
there are two pieces to this testing bit
designing the test
and making sure in the end that you
interpret the performance on the test
well
the second bit is what a statistician
helps you with the first bit what should
the test actually be that is the part
that the business decision maker is
responsible for and that is the part
that you don't learn in any course
unfortunately but that really is the
missing piece in how machine learning is
practiced today